So, we just showed that the domain and the range function are both all the real
numbers. But still, from looking at this graph, points B and D seem to stand
out. As we saw before, B and D both represent changes in the direction of, of
the slope of the graph. They also kind of look like a peak and a valley. Now,
let's compare this to another kind of peak or valley that we've seen before.
Now, let's say that in addition to this curve, we have a second one on the set
of axes. It's another function, and this time, it's just a parabola, a shape
that we've seen many times before. Now, I'm going to label the vertex on this
parabola, which we know is a special point for it, and I'm going to call that
point G. I've given you four choices to choose from to figure out what is
special about points B, D, and G. Is one of them a global minimum, or a global
maximum, or a relative minimum, or a relative maximum? Please pick the proper
letter to go in each box.